[Music]
there's a new speedster he's a threat to
the whole city I have to face him you
don't have a lifespan I have to try
John's violent
[Music]
do
[Applause]
didn't have to be like this flash you
don't know what it's like getting there
to get out where's she's still in the
world I left behind along with the rest
of my insurance policy chief Singh and
your friend Camila they're safe
how long is up to you what they're gonna
kill me there's no need for that
they're wounded you lost your speed and
your healing is not what it used to be
you're not much of a threat are you
[Music]
you just stay out of my way flash and
I'll stay out of yours I have unfinished
business to attend a whole deliberate
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new flash season 6
episode 18 video also talked about
Easter eggs from episode 17 but god
speed is back and they are doing a bunch
of flash rebirth storyline the
showrunner explained what's going on
with the rest of the season and all the
newer flash story that they're pulling
from so if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we're doing an Amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite flash rebirth
moment on the video so we'll just start
with all the god speed stuff the flash
rebirth stuff that'll talk about Easter
eggs from episode 17 so god speed his
back obviously and it's supposed to be
the real god speed this time not the
fake ones from season 6 episode 1
remember when we opened up in that first
scene they said there have been several
fake god speeds before this one they
believed that they were all copies sent
back into the past by someone and it
sounds like the real god speed is either
behind it or he's tied to it somehow so
it sounds like we'll also find out what
was going on with that fake god speed
army and this is supposed to be the
post-crisis rebooted version of god
speed there's a different actor that's
playing the character underneath the
mask but if you don't remember from
season 5 the person that did the voice
for god speed when he was in his full
costume was actually benedict wang who
most of you probably remember from the
jurassic world' movies or gotham when he
played Hugo Strange he's actually pretty
cool so hopefully they brought him back
to do the voice for God speed even
though technically this is supposed to
be a different version of the character
I wasn't a huge fan of the version that
they did during season 5 the one that
they turned into the discount velocity-9
speedster that Nora was able to take
down on her first day with powers that
was pretty lame but the title of next
week's episode is pay the piper because
it's also a big Pied Piper episode and
they're gonna pay off that scene from
episode 10 right after a crisis on
Infinite Earths when we had the Pied
Piper cameo remember Barry found out
that in the new earth prime rebooted
timeline he found out that he had done
something terrible to Pied Piper in the
past and he totally hated him but now
because he doesn't have his speed
anymore the premise of the episode is
that God speed comes he doesn't have the
speed he needs to defeat him so he needs
Pied Pipers help to take down god speed
thus he has to pay the piper you also
probably notice that their artificial
Speed Force Big Bang device didn't work
in that opening scene Pied Piper is also
a genius tech wizard just like they are
he worked at STAR Labs under
reverse-flash so once Barry is able to
make nice with him early prediction
he'll probably be able to help them fix
their Speed Force generator the mirror
master stuff seems like it's on pause
next week maybe they'll be some kind of
post credit scene for her because in two
weeks episode 19 is going to be the
season finale this year in the title of
that episode is success is assured which
is a line of dialogue that all the MIR
pod people were saying during last
week's episodes success is assured so it
sounds like whatever's happening with a
mere master storyline they're gonna wrap
that up in episode 19 as for what
happens with the Speed Force storyline
there are a couple things that they
could do with that couple directions
they could take it but because of what
the showrunner said it sounds like
they're leaning more in the Josh
Williamson flash rebirth direction with
the story which means either the forced
quest storyline or possible speed for
storm the showrunner just said that he
felt like the show had not done enough
stories from the newer flash comics as
opposed to always leaning on the Mark
Waid and Geoff Johns comics for the past
five seasons
they're the classics they have some
really awesome stories obviously but
there's so much untapped potential and
fresh new story that hasn't been retread
a thousand times in the brand new flash
rebirth comics so it's a no brainer that
they would start doing the newer stories
so as part of that it's possible that
they take the speedforce storyline in a
forced quest direction obviously
changing a little bit for the TV show
where Barry maybe unwittingly unlocks
all the other cosmic forces that coexist
with the Speed Force and they deal with
that
during season 7 because remember there's
only two episodes left it's not as
they're gonna wrap that up in two
episodes also because Red Death and God
speed are newer flash rebirth characters
and the showrunner said that they would
be doing more characters from the flash
rebirth comics it makes sense that they
would do more with them during season 7
to now reverse flash is a flash rebirth
character he has a big storyline but it
sounds like based on what they're doing
within the last couple of episodes that
they want to do him in a very different
way during season 7 so that it's not
just him coming back again for the
billionth time I've already talked about
how I think they're foreshadowing Red
Death this season with all the major
twist the Dragon Ball Gogi diffusion
speedsters reverse flash taking over
other
bodies with his negative speed force
energy and even though this grant gustin
black flash suit was just a special
costume test I really hope they go back
to that idea and have some fun with it
during season seven there are a lot of
black flash storylines happening as part
of the forced quest storyline in flash
rebirth if you're not a big comic book
reader don't worry whenever they wind up
pulling from the comics I'll talk about
it whenever I do videos for those
episodes but hopefully that explains
what's going on with the rest of the
season episode 18 in that episode 19
then they're on break to the fall in all
the stuff that they were not able to
film for the last three episodes this
season because of the virus
they'll just cover that storyline at the
beginning of season 7 so hopefully
that'll give them something stronger to
start off the season with and I think
that's gonna get into a lot of the
reverse-flash red death stuff because
they said that originally in episode 20
or the planned episode 20 this season
season finale there was going to be some
epic reverse-flash season 7 cliffhanger
that they were gonna end on so even
though they can't do that this season
they were never going to fully pay off
the big reverse-flash red death twist
until next season anyway everyone let me
know in the comments though what do you
want them to do with godspeed red death
the other flash rebirth storyline stuff
forced quest during season 7 remember
season 7 is actually the last season on
grant gustin's contract so he'll have to
resign or renegotiate four more seasons
if he wants to come back for flash
season 8 and if Grant Gustin doesn't
come back for flash season 8 that's the
end of the show but it sounds like he
will it sounds like he's really excited
he's been talking about it he's been
talking about being really excited for
the Superman Tyler hoechlin TV show
that's gonna be happening later this
year so maybe they'll also do some flash
Superman crossovers they kind of teased
that during crisis on Infinite Earths
where berry winds up being this huge
Superman fanboy so maybe we will
actually get a comic book accurate flash
vs. Superman race they kind of did that
with flash and Supergirl during the very
first flash Supergirl crossover when
that show was still on CBS but obviously
they can do a comic-book accurate
version of that you would want to see
them try supposed to all your theories
in the comments below they'll probably
some more trailers for Wonder Woman 1984
coming up in the next couple of months
what's gonna happen after the flash
finale is that the star girl TV show is
gonna take over its timeslot I've seen
the first couple of episodes
all ready so I'll probably post some
kind of review or breakdown video for
those and just explain what's going on
with it and what my thoughts are on it I
was storm and sidekick
the Justice Society of America died
saving the world
if you haven't seen any of the trailers
it's basically a Justice Society TV show
so if you remember they did a version of
the Justice Society on legends of
tomorrow this is a completely different
group of actors they're not reusing
about legends of tomorrow stuff they
spent way more money on it so it's way
more core just to society if you're a
big fan of that team from the comics
while you wait for everything click here
to learn about the brand-new spider-man
TV shows that might be coming to Disney
Plus in the next couple of years and
click here for my Mandalorian season 2
teaser trailer video thank you so much
for watching everyone stays safe I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]